un mois de la coupe du monde de football
la tension monte chez les responsables
de la sécurité des stades en france afin
de tester leur dispositif en grandeur
nature les forces de police chargés de
la sécurité du stade de france se sont
livré une dernière répétition c'était
samedi soir à l'occasion de la finale de
la coupe de france entre lens et le psg
tous les ingrédients y étaient réunis un
public de supporters chaleureux voit un
peu chaud reportage qui lui sert ya ces
manuels avec leur match à eux se joue
dans les tribus parce qu'on arrive à
voir ce qui ce qui brandit la un
supporter a été repéré un objet suspect
à la main celles auxquelles celui avec
ceux qui se tiennent leur parle d'abord
le jeu consultez le celui avec les
bonbons sur le côté il a caché leur soif
et une longueur comme nous sommes au
coeur du dispositif de sécurité du stade
de france
ici sont contrôlées les 150 de caméras
qui surveillent les tribunes et les
abords du stade pour ce match à hauts
risques
le commissaire menault est inquiet dans
les tribunes réservées aux supporters du
psg
la tension est à son comble pourtant la
police ne se montrent pas c'est l'une
des nouveautés du système de sécurité de
la coupe du monde
à l'intérieur du stade un service
d'ordre privé ici en orange est chargée
d'encadrer les supporters ce sont des
stadiers
rien que
moi aussi illustration des bagarres
éclatent entre supporters du psg à
l'arrière des gradins les stadiers sont
prises à partie le calme ne reviendra
qu'au bout de quelques minutes
tout cela sous l'oeil des crs à aucun
moment la police n'est intervenue
désormais les forces de l'ordre ne sont
engagés qu'en dernier recours
tout cela dans un but précis c'est
d'obliger l'organisateur à prendre en
compte une partie de la sécurité qu'il
ne pourrait pas quand même incombait en
totalité à l'état l'état qui retrouve
ses prérogatives dès la fin du match ce
soir là sur les champs elysées les crs
ont été obligés d'intervenir
la violence en dehors des stades c'est
d'ailleurs ce que craignent le plus les
organisateurs de la coupe du monde